roadblock in Kashgar is a tense place
right now roadblocks are dotted across
the city soldiers gather under the
statue of Chairman Mao a reminder of
who's in charge here they're looking for
extremist material our taxi driver
explains bones are examined social
networks plot he describes the bloody
murder last month of the city's Imam by
fellow Muslims three men he says
repeatedly stabbed and clubbed the Imam
to death with 2,700 miles to the west of
Beijing just 200 miles from the borders
with Afghanistan and Pakistan it is a
place which feels not remotely Chinese
this is the heartland of the Uighur
Muslims the look the food the language
none of it is Chinese just yards from
the mosque where the Imam was stabbed we
meet a weger willing to talk most fear
government reprisals he tells me the
Imam deserved to die he says he was a
stooge of china's communist government
to a destroying weaker culture and
restricting their religion this is what
he means signs on the street corners
spelling out new policies here for
Muslims no vales and no bids for me why
is it not hard for you done can't have
readable
yeah understood yeah the wiegers are now
a minority in a province that was once
there's Chinese from the rest of the
country the hand have moved in ancient
wieger homes are bulldozed tower blocks
now dominate it's not popular since the
beginning of the year more than a
hundred people have died in attacks by
wieger Muslims where are we oh thank you
so these days you enter the Chinese
shopping centers through metal detectors
bags are scanned people are on edge
so what that is clearly is a drill this
is the Chinese part of town mahan
Chinese part of town they're very
concerned that there could be an attack
by wiegers we leave our hotel early the
following morning your authorities don't
welcome journalists here we must move
every day and we're heading south keep
it quiet him were less than 100 miles
now from the borders with Pakistan and
Afghanistan and the accusation from the
Chinese government is that Islamist
extremists are crossing those borders
and radicalizing the population here
this is where the government's war on
terror is at its most intense and where
the truth is so hard to establish we
reach a suburb of yar khant county the
internet has been cut people's movement
restricted it's a place where the
government says it killed 96 terrorists
exactly a month ago week as those say it
was a massacre weger exiles claimed two
thousand died the truth we won't find
out our driver is too intimidated to
stormed alarm and so as this chinese war
on terror intensifies so two daz the
resentment the religious extremists are
among this population their efforts to
recruit are only being made as yet mark
stone Sky News in China's Xinjiang
province
ultra